nadia belle journaliste et directrice de
femmes radio-tv bonjour oui merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation des
arts de dizaines de milliers de
manifestants à alger on a un peu de
chiffres de quelles informations à ce
que vous disposez en termes de
participation et en termes aussi
peut-être d'interpellations alors
imposantes manifestations et
mobilisations toujours aussi massive non
seulement alger la capitale mais aussi
les 48 willaya mais aussi comme vous
l'avez si bien dit dans votre
présentation ici à paris à lyon et dans
d'autres villes a aujourd'hui 7 grandes
dates historiques le 22 février est
fêtée célébré un peu partout j'ai
entendu dans votre reportage des
personnes qui ne veulent pas encore
célébré ça parce que il n'y a pas eu la
chute totale du régime il y a eu un
homme qui est tombé
bouteflika le président déchu mais le
système est toujours là c'est dire que
le combat doit se poursuivre et sauf
miracle qui aujourd'hui fait entrer
l'algérie dans une nouvelle ère parce
qu'il faut le dire il faut reconnaître
et vous me tende et justement la perche
pour dire merci à ce grand peuple
héroïque à ce peuple qui a démontré au
monde entier sa résistance et sa
mobilisation non violente s'il n'ya d'où
la révolution du sourire j'ai envie de
dire à ce peuple à cette jeunesse à
toutes ces femmes qui grâce à elle tous
les vendredis à mobilisation bien sûr
cette jeunesse
qui est mobilisé autour des universités
tous les mardis félicitations et merci
au peuple algérien
le irak fait face à un défi tels quels
sont les éléments qui pourraient lui
permettre de satisfaire la population
algérienne
alors bonne question moi j'ai envie de
dire aujourd'hui il faut pas se
contenter de dire le bilan est positif
le grand vainqueur de ce cher axa fait
le peuple algérien mais il ya encore
d'autres étapes à franchir
le peuple est en train de se structurer
on a toujours dit que le chirac n'a pas
de leader n'a pas de visage il ya eu le
pad et les assises de la société civile
il y a aujourd'hui de paix hier donc le
manifeste il y a effectivement dans ce
manifeste les préalables de la
transition
c'est dire qu'aujourd'hui le chèque
n'est pas une coquille vide c'est pas de
juste des personnes qui manifestent tous
les vendredis mais ils veulent justement
ils sont conscients de l'enjeu
ils veulent une algérie nouvelle et une
transition préalable et l'un très
concrètement comment est-ce qu'il se
structurent ce mouvement de contestation
populaire on l'a dit il dédie comment se
structure aujourd'hui politiquement
notamment le irak alors que l'autre
politiquement ce n'est pas un parti
politique comme son nom l'indiqué à qui
veut dire mouvement c'est un mouvement
d'où l'absence d'ailleurs de deux
leaders
il n'y a pas de leader et lui il n'y a
pas de leaders autoproclamés
alors comment il se structure et bas par
la plateforme par ce manifeste où il y à
toutes les revendications où il ya
effectivement les préalables de la
transition qui vont nous amener vers une
algérie nouvelle qui vont rompre avec ce
système et ce système est condamné à
disparaître si ce n'est pas dans
l'immédiat parce que un nom de combat de
lutte de résistance pacifique n'est pas
suffisant il faut maintenir ce bras de
fer et continuer le combat
et quoi qu'il en soit si le cheylas qui
gagnera et le régime militaire est
obligé de faire avec ce contre-pouvoir
parce que les protestataires estiment
aujourd'hui toujours que l'objectif
principal de la révolution à savoir le
changement de politique en faveur d'un
état civil et non militaire cet objectif
n'est toujours pas attendre mais c'est
tout à fait le cas
cher consoeur c'est tout à fait le cas
beaucoup de gens vous disent 'nous nous
vivons aujourd'hui dans une algérie avec
le bouteflika sont abdelaziz
ça veut dire quoi d'autre vous disent
c'est que le cadre la photo du 4
présidentielle qui a changé c'est on a
remplacé le président déchu par la photo
de type bonne de boules qui n'a pas la
légitimité le peuple le shaq ne lui
reconnaît pas cette légitimité parce que
cette élection président un président en
ciel a été rejeté massivement par leur
force est de constater aujourd'hui si
vous permettez que le cac s'est imposé
hier c'est un événement sans précédent
le 22 février a été décrété journée
nationale par le président actuel par le
présent d'interoute et pour la première
fois les médias algériens nous montre
les photos et les images du chirac et
des débats sont ouverts aussi l'occasion
de remercier rt france qui est très
regardée en algérie et bravo pour toutes
les informations que vous avez relayés
pendant sept pendant toute une année
alors le président d'el mahdi de tebnine
répète qu'il a pris l'engagement de
satisfaire les revendications de la rue
on a quand même sentiment qu'il oscille
entre dialogues et répression des
manifestations
passés les 2 c les deux en fait parce
que il a tendu la main mais le shérif
n'a pas accepté il a rejeté cette main
tendue aujourd'hui en reconnaissant que
le 22 c'est une date historique à
marquer d'une pierre blanche dans
l'histoire de l'algérie et reconnaître
et décrété que ça soit ça c'est que
c'est une journée nationale
c'est une façon de récupérer cette date
il n'en est rien on a un peuple
aujourd'hui qui est très éclairé qui a
déjoué toutes les manoeuvres et ça ça
fait partie des manoeuvres politiques du
système qui perdure et qui se recyclent
abdel-majid tebboune qui visiblement
n'arrive pas à convaincre le miracle les
protestataires malgré l'adoption le très
serré de ce plan d'action du
gouvernement avec comme credo vous en
parliez l'algérie nouvelle pour la
simple et bonne raison qu on compte
encore une fois nous avons un peuple
éclairé un peuple qui merite le nobel de
la paix 2020 le peuple a compris que te
boon c'est une façade civile que
derrière cette façade c'est l'armée
algérienne qui pilote mais reste que le
pouvoir les activistes anti
antisystème peuvent trouver aujourd'hui
un terrain d'entente
comment est ce que vous voyez les choses
en quelques mots il peut y avoir des
négociations mais avec le respect de
cette plate forme et se manifeste qui
justement mais en clair les préalables
de la transition
il faudrait que l'armée algérienne que
le président actuel entendent réellement
les revendre aux revendications de ce
schéma et non pas essayer de jouer le
pourrissement vous avez dit le bâton il
ne faut pas jouer une bonne
pourrissement parce que pacifique c'est
la révolution du sourire il le peuple ne
veut pas faire la guerre il est passé
par des violences et aujourd'hui il veut
la paix merci d'être venu nous donner
votre regard nadia b journaliste
directrice de femmes radio tv